our other top story tonight violence
within ccsd classrooms school board
trustees holding a special meeting today
to say that something needs to change
how many educators have we lost due to
them not wanting to deal with this how
is this violence in schools affecting
other areas of the district
a report from ccsd shows there have been
more than 5 300 violent incidents so far
this school year harassment or threats
accounted for the most cases we do have
the full report posted to our website at
eight newsnow dot com and on the heels
of that report the aclu is demanding
answers from the school district
specifically
about that video of a student getting
punched by another student without
anybody stopping it our victoria saha
continues our coverage with details
about the incident at las vegas high
school
the attack at las vegas high school was
recorded and went viral on social media
causing an angry uproar for many i was
pretty outraged robert lankford has been
hired by the victim of the attack a lack
of intervention on the part of anyone
that was the thing that that scared me
for all of us we're not going to show
you the video to protect the victim but
we can describe to you what happened a
15 year old was approached from behind
and repeatedly punched knocking her
unconscious no one stepped in to help a
teacher was heard telling the attacker
to stop the aclu says the victim was hit
a total of 30 times the right to an
education is a civil right
hard to say that you have that right if
you're being brutally beaten down in
your classroom there's many parts of
this incident that's concerning for the
aclu they tell me when the girl regained
consciousness the staff reportedly made
her call her mom to tell her what
happened our client deserves
respect deserves justice and we're
hoping that engaging here will create
positive change they say the victim is
still suffering from health issues and
has not been back to school as for the
alleged attacker she was cited for
battery but it's unclear if she was
allowed back victoria saha live local
now now the aclu has reached out to the
school district for answers on exactly
what happened that day and they are
waiting for a report they hope their
push for the school district to enforce
stricter policies they hope they do that
when it comes to this violence